so sehr geehrte damen und herren
herzlich willkommen
es gehört zu
unserer pressekonferenz vom
parteivorsitz markus söder an mir nach
der konstituierenden sitzung der csu im
deutschen bundestag wir haben nochmal im
nachgang zur bundestagswahl uns auch
über die situation unterhalten und
festgestellt ja es ist ein sehr sehr
schwieriges
wahlergebnis es ist eine niederlage für
die union und es ist eine der
unnötigsten niederlagen der vergangenen
jahrzehnte
wir haben auf dem schlussspurt noch mal
aufgeholt deswegen ist es uns gelungen
dass wir die landesgruppe die csu im
deutschen bundestag stabil jetzt bei
bundestagsabgeordnete 45 mandaten halten
konnten alle wahlkreise bis auf einen
wahlkreis konnten in bayern gewonnen
werden was auch damit zu tun hat dass
wir in bayern eine sehr starke
wahlbeteiligung hatten das heißt die
mobilisierung am schluss auch mit der
thematik
richtungsentscheidung mit dem warnen vor
dem drohenden linksrutsch hat wähler und
wählerinnen mobilisiert an der wahl
teilzunehmen und erheblich zu diesem
ergebnis und auch den gewinnen der
wahlkreise mit beigetragen
wir haben am wahlabend festgestellt dass
es jetzt unterschiedliche optionen gibt
auch für
regierungskonstellationen
dazu muss man sagen dass dieser eindruck
natürlich auch im besonderen maße
dadurch entstanden ist dass es einen
quasi gleichstand auf den
fernsehbildschirmen von cdu csu und spd
gegeben hat der hat sich ja im laufe der
nacht und dann am montag auch verändert
die spd liegt
doch jetzt nicht zu deutlich aber doch
vor den unionsparteien
die fraktionen sind ähnlich groß aber
die spd ist knapp größer von daher kann
man
keinen
automatischen anspruch auf eine
regierung für die union
reklamieren sondern muss deutlich machen
dass es auch verständnis dafür gibt es
die grünen und die fdp
als erstes mit der spd sprechen
ich sage aber ausdrücklich dazu es
bleibt dabei wir haben ein angebot
gemacht ein angebot zu gesprächen über
eine mögliche jamaika-koalition
dazu muss natürlich sondierungen auch
geben können
dieses angebot bedeutet aber kein
angebot zu einer selbstaufgabe wir haben
gerade noch mal im rahmen der
landesgruppe auch genau darüber
gesprochen dass es eine bereitschaft
gibt zur verantwortungsübernahme
aber kein angebot zur entkernung der
union um in ein regierungsbündnis zu
kommen
wir wissen dass
dies die woche der entscheidungen ist
dass die woche der entscheidungen sowohl
was den politischen kurs anbelangt als
auch was das personal anbelangt
wir wollen auch eine entscheidung heute
herbeiführen über die frage der führung
der gemeinsamen fraktion
ich höre nur das ist der diskussionen
darüber gibt ob man
eine entscheidung vielleicht vermeiden
könnte ich will das hier ausdrücklich
sagen wenn eine fraktion zu einer
konstitution zusammenkommt also die
erste sitzung nach einer bundestagswahl
man hat sie die aufgabe auch dafür zu
sorgen dass ordnung entsteht und diese
ordnung wird als erstes dadurch
hergestellt dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende gewählt wird und
deswegen ist es unser wunsch an dieser
stelle dass dies auch heute genauso
stattfindet gerade nach einer schweren
niederlage darf es keine folgefehler
geben und
einer dieser folge fehler wäre personal
entscheidungen die notwendig sind zu
vermeiden oder zu verschieben deswegen
werben wir genau dafür dies jetzt zu tun
bedanke mich ausdrücklich beim
parteivorsitzenden markus söder für die
exzellente und gute zusammenarbeit
werden die wahlanalyse jetzt auch
gemeinsam mit
vorgenommen in der landesgruppe und die
landesgruppe ist fest entschlossen die
diese wahlperiode in einem guten
miteinander zwischen parteiführung
landesgruppen führung zu bestreiten
ja von meiner seite einen schönen guten
tag zunächst einmal gratulation an
alexander dobrindt ich habe ihnen wie es
tradition war und ist das
parteivorsitzender zur wiederwahl bei
der landesgruppe vorgeschlagen und er
wurde mit ganz ganz großer mehrheit dort
in diesem amt bestätigt deswegen viel
erfolg weiter auf gute zusammenarbeit
ich schätze ihn sehr weil wir genau in
diesen zeiten seine erfahrung ist eine
stabilität aber auch sein wissen um die
mechanismen die in berlin jetzt in den
nächsten tagen entscheiden sind ganz
besonders nutzen werden
spannende tage für deutschland schwere
zeiten für die union meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren es geht
einfach mal festzuhalten ist dass am
sonntag eine schwere niederlage war das
war eine schwere niederlage
nicht weil der abstand vielleicht nicht
so groß wäre zur zur spd sondern weil
insgesamt eher auf breiter front einen
einbruch haben deswegen ist es auch
wichtig dass man ein wahlergebnis
respektiert dazu gehört für mich auch
vom stil her an der stelle noch einmal
weil es bislang kaum erfolgt ist olaf
scholz gratuliere dazu dass er die
meisten stimmen in deutschland
willkommen aber ich will es an der
stelle ausdrücklich auch als
parteivorsitzender der csu machen
aus diesem wahlergebnis des klaren platz
zwei bedingt lässt sich nun wirklich
kein regierungsauftrag moralisch
legitimiert aber die verantwortung
bleibt wir müssen jetzt haltung zeigen
wir müssen haltung zeigen souveränität
und müssen die aufgaben die wir haben
erfüllen wir sind wie immer zur
verantwortung bereit wenn es darum geht
deutschland zu einer stabilen regierung
zu verhelfen wir glauben nicht daran
dass die ampel für sie die besten
chancen darauf bietet aber ganz klar ist
das natürlich zunächst einmal das nahe
liegt nicht nur bei den umfragen gezeigt
wird sondern weil der die meisten
stimmen hat einfach so ein angebot der
ausgesprochen hat an grüne und fdp wir
sind bereit zu gesprächen natürlich aber
wenn uns dabei nicht anbiedern und wir
werden natürlich nicht um jeden preis
versuchen irgendwie eine regierung
zusammen zu bringen sondern zunächst
einmal muss von den denkbaren partnern
überhaupt gesagt werden und relativ klar
kann man sich das vorstellen oder nicht
und zwar nicht den endlosschleifen
sondern relativ bald in einer
überschaubaren seriösen zeitfolge das
muss er über nacht erfolgen aber
natürlich nicht wie es 2017 der fall war
für uns ist jedenfalls klar
jamaika ist sicher kein selbstläufer und
deswegen weil es so ist zunächst einmal
bereitschaft zur verantwortung aber
nicht bereit zur selbstaufgabe
wie es jetzt die nächsten stunden und
tage weitergeht zum einer ist wichtig
wir haben knapp für die csu schon mal
mit alexander dobrindt an einer marke
arbeitet für denkbare gespräche wenn sie
den stattfinden das jetzt auch mit der
cdu an der stelle besprechen wir sind ja
da an dem austausch wichtig ist dass wir
jetzt auch stabilität und ordnung in
überhaupt unsere prozessstrukturen
bringen müssen überhaupt gesprächsbereit
sein die ganzen meldungen die jetzt
übrigens laufen zeigen nur die
nervosität
also gibt es meldungen wer welche
verhandlungen führen soll die sind
genauso ohne unser zutun entstanden und
den wir uns genauso überraschen lassen
wie sie genauso wie melde und jetzt
laufen beim fraktionsvorsitz alles
geklärt ist alles zeugt natürlich nur
von einer gewissen sehr große nervosität
und anspannung vieler beteiligter da
wird unsere aufgabe sein in dieser
aufgeregten zeit auch in der union ein
stückweit ordnung und linien und
vertrauen und zusammenhalt zu
stabilisieren
wir werden jetzt dann noch einige
gespräche führen bis heute nachmittag in
erster linie armin laschet alle
denkbaren kandidaten die es ja so im
gespräch gekommen übrigen alle aus
nordrhein westfalen insofern ist ja auch
relativ klar dass der parteivorsitzende
der cdu und sagen wir mal oberst in
afghanistan einfach noch mal überlegt
wie man das koordinieren kann wichtig
ist glaube ich schon dass mehr
arbeitsfähig sind also was das
entscheidende ist dass wir heute
nachmittag waren oder am frühen abend
arbeitsfähigkeit herstellen an
sprachfähigkeit und auch einige wie sie
prokura etablieren wie solche
verhandlungen stattfinden können weil
das ist ja bei solch schwierigen
bündnissen in der konstellation
braucht es ja dann auch
verhandlungsmandat die da sind uns macht
es ja kein sind die werden übrigens
immer von cdu/csu gemeinsam gebildet die
von einem allein deswegen ist uns
wichtig dass wir da heute jedenfalls
unsere prozessstrukturen herstellen dass
wir die handlungsfähigkeit etablieren
und jeweils zunächst bei der
landesgruppe die csu ist komplett
handlungsfähig sowohl mit dem
vorsitzenden als auch mit dem
stellvertretenden geborenen schnell für
den fraktionslosen wir werden auch die
fraktionsgemeinschaft wiederherstellen
unverändert die bislang weil es das
wichtigste gemeinsamkeit zu betonen und
dann am ende wird man sehen ob und man
gespräche da sind wir bieten es auch den
anderen an also partnern aus fdp und
grünen gespräche zu führen aber ich
würde es mal so sagen zunächst mal ist
die spd als diejenige die stimmen voran
hut anzug und wenn das nicht
funktionieren sollte das nicht
funktionieren sollte dann sind wir zu
jedem gesprächen bereit in deutschland
muss regierungsfähig sein und muss
regierungsfähig bleiben für unser land
für die menschen aber auch in der mitte
europas haben wir da eine internationale
binde und verantwortungsvoll zion aber
wir müssen umgekehrt auch einfach das
wahlergebnis akzeptieren und nicht
versuchen sozusagen über alle
mathematischen möglichkeiten dann doch
noch ein erfolg her zu stellen wir uns
an der wallone in der dimension versagt
geblieben ist
nur eine frage zu der war schnell
entschieden
die union der
oppositionskandidat solchen aktionen
stand
wir wollen alles wunderbar
ich wisst ihr das erneuern der
installation gibt es nicht doch
irgendwann die wechselfrist in der
berühmten pianisten christoph nationen
erfolgreiche sanierung die erste
bundeskanzlerin
das ist jetzt eine frage die ist technik
also daraus jetzt also und es auch klar
zu beantworten
ich werde unter keinen umständen einen
vorschlag machen einen
fraktionsvorsitzenden für vier oder
sechs wochen zu bilden
sondern das was wir brauchen ist
arbeitsfähigkeit
ordnung
stabilität
und ein mandat
und das hat man wenn man langfristig
auch eine perspektive hat so eine
fraktion zu führen dazu gibt es regeln
in unserer gemeinsamen ordnung und
unserem gemeinsamen
fraktions vertrag
das heißt nicht dass man nicht davon
auch in bestimmten maße abweichen könnte
aber das sind technische diskussionen
zu dem maße wo sie dann politisch werden
da habe ich jetzt einen hinweis darauf
gegeben nämlich wenn wir über vier oder
sechs wochen oder so was reden dazu habe
ich keine bereitschaft
ich lese so vieles nicht lese wie
wahlforscher sich äußern wie eine wahl
ausgegangen wäre so oder so ob
einem das schmeichelt oder nicht sei
völlig dahin gestellt weil es völlig
irrelevantes zunächst mal ein
wahlergebnis das kann man nicht
uminterpretieren oder um wünschen wie es
ist ist zunächst mal so das hat man zu
akzeptieren das ist finde ich eine
grundregel der demokratie man muss auch
jeder selber dann seine verantwortung
definieren die er dabei hat
und auch schauen wie man daraus positive
energie ziehen kann meine aufgabe ist
das parteivorsitzender das mandat hier
war zunehmend für die csu dann auch wenn
sondierungsgespräche wenn mit alexander
dobrindt zusammen mal sehen welche runde
überhaupt werden es sicherlich wenn es
sondierungs unten gibt nicht 2017
wiederholen endlose gespräche und pausen
auf den balkonen das glaube ich ist
nicht etwas was die leute begeistert hat
da waren sich schnell und zügig
entscheidungen gerade weil die
konstellation so knapp und instabil und
so viele partner beteiligt sind meine
aufgabe ist jetzt als parteivorsitzender
alles andere ist eine
spekulation hier die glaube ich keinen
nährboden hat und ich habe es gelesen
alles ich kenne dazu nix kann nur eines
sagen die besten chancen kanzler zu
werden hat derzeit olaf scholz eindeutig
ich wollte einfach wissen aussehen
dieser hat eine krankenakte familie
berichtet
wir waren vielleicht auch eine
entscheidung
welche anschließend kann die schau
stellen und auch drogen achten an ihrer
seite
oder
die frage der fraktion
ob es dazu entscheidungen ist der
personalentscheidungen aus meiner sicht
heute müssen die sein ob es da jetzt
kandidaturen unterschiedlichster art
gibt kann ich zurzeit nicht sagen ich
weiß von einer kandidatur die mir
signalisiert worden ist
als brinkhaus so weitere sind mir noch
nicht angemeldet das muss aber auch
nicht sein ich leite die wahl zwar da
aber das muss nicht sein das ist ja auch
aus der versammlung heraus
möglich und deswegen kann ich nur sagen
dass mir aus medienberichten zur zeit
nichts weiteres bekannt ist also nahm
ich versucht in der cdu kann sich so
eine kernaufgabe heute alexander
dobrindt vorzuschlagen eine schnelle
entscheidung schneller vorschlag mit
einem klaren ergebnis jetzt kommt es da
von den fraktionsvorsitz etablieren es
ist nicht so leicht da gibt es mehrere
modelle mehrere vorschläge an uns wird
keiner der vorschläge scheitern und was
wir auch nicht wollen wir werden auch
nicht neben abgeordneten seien recht
vorenthalten im zweifelsfall wählen oder
kandidieren zu können ich glaube das ist
in so einer phase werde es auch ein
schwieriges vorgehen denn gerade das ist
ja auch nach einem wahlergebnis sind ja
auch die abgeordneten sehr aufgewühlt
weil sie die erfahrungen mitbringen von
vor einigen wochen hatten wahlkampf und
auf der anderen seite auch den
hoffnungen und manchmal auch den den
vorstellungen wie es weitergehen soll
also ist es schon eine sehr knifflige
und auch schwierige aufgabe da wird
jetzt noch einmal gesprochen welches die
beste lösung ist und welche wohl
konsensfähig ist wenn es keinen
einheitlichen konsens gibt ist es auch
kein beinbruch dass gewählt wird das ist
der normalfall der demokratie und
insofern sind wir es noch gespannt was
bis 17 18 uhr passiert und welche
meldungen auch zwischendrin alle
kursieren glaube am heutigen tag ist
relativ viel möglich anmeldungen was
dann am ende herauskommt dass das werden
wir sehen und zum anderen habe ich schon
alles gesagt jetzt hat wenn man
wahlergebnis wir haben
was diese lage auch annehmen auch
innerlich übrigens annehmen
und und das zweite gibt eine kleine
möglichkeit glaube ich das vielleicht am
ende die ampel nicht kommen könnte und
vielleicht doch jamaika dann zum tragen
kommt wir hatten es ja vor vier jahren
in gewisser weise ähnlich nur
zeitversetzt und auch dann müssen wir
uns erstmal gut vorbereitet und wissen
was wir dann wollen das ist nämlich
übrigens auch ganz wichtig dass eine
union dann überhaupt weiß inhaltlich was
ist wie ganz besonders wichtig in einer
solchen idee und welche bereiche sieht
man sehr skeptisch und kann man nicht
betragen auch der prozess muss
ausgestattet werden also wir sind dafür
für die csu gerüstet aber auch das muss
noch erst mal organisiert werden mit der
cdu
[Musik]
auf den worten guten zusammenhalt 12
da werden viele aus
[Musik]
ich kann nur mit negativen
aber das entscheidende ist ja
sondierungen wenn sie stattfinden sind
von zwei elementen geprägt
das eine sind die inhaltlichen fragen ja
und das andere sind auch die fragen von
sympathie von chemie
hat man ein ein feeling füreinander hat
man das gespür dass auch die jeweiligen
vertreter in der lage sind
ihre fraktionen dann auf so einen weg
hin zu bewegen
wir haben
sowohl bei den
grünen als auch bei uns fraktionen die
sich sehr stark verändert haben
bei den grünen sieht was am aller
deutlichsten diese fraktion ist doppelt
so groß wie in der vergangenheit allein
deswegen sind schon die hälfte der leute
die da sind neu
auch bei uns gibt es erhebliche
veränderungen
da muss man auch ein bisschen darauf
rücksicht nehmen wie diese fraktionen
jetzt in dem jeweiligen nachwahl zustand
welche empfindungen welche emotionen
welche befindlichkeiten da herrschen wie
sie auf solche konstellationen reagieren
da hängt sehr viel natürlich sowohl an
den fraktions als auch im jeweiligen
parteivorsitzenden
dann in so eine gruppe hinein wirken zu
können und deswegen betone ich das so
ausdrücklich es hängt auch sehr viel
damit zusammen man kann auch sagen
welches vertrauen haben diese handelnden
personen
ineinander dass sie dann solche
mannschaften auch in eine stabile ein
stabiles regierungsbündnis führen können
und was jetzt die inhaltlichen fragen
angeht ich habe ja mehr als deutlich
gesagt das ist zu keiner selbstaufgabe
keiner entkernung der union kommen darf
um in ein bündnis hinein zu wachsen und
das worum es geht da könnte man jetzt
eine vielzahl von punkten
aufzählen aber
verhandlungen sondierungen sollten
geprägt sein von dem willen
wirtschaftliches wachstum und dynamik in
deutschland zu erzeugen und es nicht
abzuwürgen
ja den klimaschutz auch deutlich zu
beschleunigen
aber auch sehr klare vorgaben für innere
und äußere sicherheit zu machen
bündnisverpflichtungen einzuhalten
deutliches bekenntnis
zur sicherheit und zur verteidigung
abzugeben das sind kernaufgaben über die
man sich in einer sortierung unterhalten
muss waren ja bei allen drei punkten
vorhersehbar glauben kann dass da auch
hürden drin sind zu denen man brücken
entwickeln muss und dieses vertrauen
muss man in solchen gesprächen entstehen
also ja da sind überall nachgedacht und
daran gearbeitet ich glaube das
entscheidende ist jetzt folgendes
noch mal ein bisschen lernen aus
prozessen der vergangenheit der prozess
jamaika 1 der dann scheiterte war der
sich gegenseitig überfordernde versuch
das er tränende herauszustellen und dann
letztlich
eine maximale beute situation für jede
gruppe zu schaffen und am ende gab es
dann eben die jeweilige der forderung
dass ein partner die fdp damals gesagt
hat sie glaubt nicht dass dieser
gemeinschaftliche gibt das heißt es
jetzt umgekehrt
wichtigste ist dass man zwei dinge
entwickelt ein gemeinsames verständnis
von einem neuen narrativ an der
regierung also die überschrift ist schon
ganz entscheidend was soll diese
überschrift dann auch sein für unser
land
da gibt es so viele politikfelder die
kann man so oder so in den kompromissen
demokraten müssen kompromisse finden das
ist unter solchen partner natürlich
möglichst ging er mit der spd auch wenn
wir das sagen darf was muss ein narrativ
entwickelt werden dass tatsächlich für
diese modernität steht das für
erneuerung steht das aber auch dafür
steht da die menschen im land
mitzunehmen also muss für ein stabiles
und starkes staatsverständnis stehen für
die bereitschaft zur innovation und
forschung aber eben auch für eine
ökologische gerechtigkeit so das ist
ganz entscheidend ist das eine und dann
das zweite ist glaube ich das
allerwichtigste wie immer in der politik
neben den geschriebenen vertragstext
braucht es auch einen gemeinsamen
teamgeist vertrauen
sozusagen auch den das gegenseitige
aufeinander verlassen können und das
entwickelt sich manchmal in solchen
gesprächen hast ich weiß nicht ob es
jetzt zum beispiel tatsächlich so einen
gemeinsamen teamgeist bei der antrag
geben könnte auch da fehlt mir noch ein
bisschen die vorstellungskraft wenn ich
das sagen darf aber das kann auch immer
wachsen in solchen gesprächen aber das
ist dann ganz entscheiden und daraus
könnte dann eben auch viele entstehen
aber noch einmal
die reihenfolge und die struktur ist
relativ klar und man darf nicht
vergessen natürlich zählt das
wahlergebnis aber ich finde schon auch
das gesellschaftliche klima und die
erwartungshaltung der bevölkerung muss
für uns schon ein maßstab sein wie man
damit umgeht also nur auf mathematik zu
setzen reicht meiner meinung nach nicht
aus sondern es braucht neben einer
sozusagen
mathematischen möglichkeit auch immer
eine gesellschaftliche und ein stück
weit auch moralische legitimation für
einen solchen regierungsauftrag die man
gemeinsam entwickeln muss
namen auf den listen der das werde nicht
abgeschafft aber
zweifel dass er der held und dann
brauchen wir
haben
zu den beiden das ist auch eine
permanente
[Musik]
keine
gewöhnlichen morgen sagen sie nicht ein
paar
also
jetzt jetzt bin ich schon etwas
überrascht
also eine gratulation an jemand der mehr
stimmen hat empfinde ich für mich
jedenfalls eher als eine stilfrage und
nicht als eine stichelei sorry ich hab
mir wirklich viel verständnis die
letzten wochen immer gehabt für für das
grab messen wie oft wir für dafür dass
lopo mieter ja wie viel lob ist gemeint
wenn ich beim fernsehduell gesagt habe
bei einem super auftritt anschreiben
nicht sie aber andere kolleginnen und
kollegen das war nicht ernst gemeint ist
sagt jetzt bewusst um zu sticheln lobte
wenn ich dann beim anderen duell nicht
schreibe heißt ahs lothar nicht also
ganz ehrlich mit diesem alter versteht
sich aus meiner sicht dass in
albernheiten die uns da wirklich in so
einer recht ernsten situation in der
sich auch unser land befindet denn es
ist ja noch nie so gewesen dass man so
unklare strukturen hatte finde ich nicht
angemessen ich hab gratuliert olaf
scholz und es ist eine gratulation an
olaf scholz die ich finde ich unter
demokraten einfach ganz normales das hat
nichts mit irgendwas anderes zu tun
die erste frage war ja ist es kritik an
einer einzigen person ein
und zweitens ich glaube dass die
demut mit der man an wahlergebnis ja
auch annehmen muss durchaus nicht nur
berechtigt sogar ein fordert dass man in
der auseinandersetzung mit diesem
wahlergebnis auch tatsachen benennen
kann und das wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich
eher verwunderlich wenn man sich
hinstellt nach einer sitzung der
landesgruppe und sagt wir haben
festgestellt es war alles großartig nein
es war nicht großartig
übrigens habe ich gerade auch alexander
dobrindt gratuliert also waren auch die
stichelei sondern auch respekt
das
ist ein neues tief
sich heute in des moines wenig
kommste reich der macht sei
zu sagen
[Musik]
wo sehen sie das vertrauen in ein
man kann unterschiedliche materien wie
ich finde es nicht schlecht wenn eine
bundesregierung den eindruck vermittelt
man ist ein team und nicht nur
verschiedene teile
es wurde ja am sonntag von allen immer
wieder gesagt ja da muss sich jeder
wiederfinden natürlich aber zum
wiederfinden gehört auch die fähigkeit
gemeinsame kompromisse zu etablieren
also man kann nicht sagen es gibt dann
drei bundesregierungen oder fans jetzt
auf union gezogen würde 4 es gibt eine
regierung für ein land und die muss auch
eine grundphilosophie entwickeln da wird
in der sache immer natürlich diskutiert
und natürlich haben auch die jeweiligen
partner unterschiedliche interessen aber
klar ist doch jeder muss in einer
demokratie wenn es um solche
konstellation heraus aus seiner
komfortzone und sollte sich jetzt auch
nichts hinter dem absoluten jedem wort
und jeden komma seines eigenen
parteiprogramms verbarrikadieren sondern
braucht sondern auch kompromisse ein
land braucht eine gute regierung und
nicht nur gute parteiprogramme das ist
glaube ich die größte herausforderung
vor der man immer wieder steht und man
braucht daneben auch das vertrauen in
diese regierung das vertrauen in die
handelnden personen und das eine union
übrigens nach so einem wahlergebnis auch
ein stückweit intern diskutiert ist auch
selbstverständlich also ist alles andere
wäre überraschend ist muss auch sein das
lässt sich auch aus meiner sicht muss
das auch parallel erfolgen wir bei uns
ich habe es ja gestern gesagt in bayern
machen auf jeden fall auch ein parallel
zu jeder form ob sondierungs überhaupt
stattfinden nicht wird sich zeigen aber
parallel dazu noch ein intensiver
vergewisserung und diskussionsprozess
auch aus diesem wahlkampf ist
aufzuarbeiten und auch noch einmal zu
überlegen was man besser machen kann
denn keiner ist frei von fehlern
und und und es gibt viele dinge die man
verbessern kann die man den letzten
wochen gemerkt hat das wollen wir auch
gemeinsam erarbeiten es ist ohnehin die
große aufgabe in zeiten von
individualisierung unterschiedliche
interessen bindekraft noch überhaupt zu
halten also integrations und bindekraft
nicht nur parteien sondern wirklich den
menschen zu entwickeln ist eine große
aufgabe von parteien von volksparteien
und wenn sie das ergebnis messen
jenseits der der auszählung der mandate
wer viel viel hat haben auch alle
volksparteien übrigens auch die spd noch
eine menge aufgaben vor sich jede
bindekraft zu entfalten wenn wahrheit
ist auch bei dieser wahl die ergebnisse
der volksparteien der klassischen
volksparteien wie wir sie kennen haben
sich doch unter einstellungen deutlich
verändert und darüber müssen auch die
parteien jedenfalls die ehemals großen
aber so groß sind sie momentan immer
deutlich nachdenken dazu muss man jetzt
sagen diese trugschluss
jeder könnte sein ding machen in einer
koalition und jeder könnte seine
speziellen themen bedienen
unbeeinflusst vom jeweils anderen
dieser trugschluss diese täuschung hat
beim letzten mal jamaika
zur
überdehnung und auch zum bruch mit
geführt da war genau die haltung dinge
diese
kunden hinein nach dem motto jeder hat
zu sein spezielles klientel und seine
spezielle vorstellung die einen machen
irgendwas im bereich von umwelt und die
anderen machen irgendwas im bereich von
steuern und
wenn da jeder den anderen machen lasst
dann geht er sehr schnell zusammen das
ergebnis war natürlich ein anderes wir
reden heute mit modernen selbstbewussten
parteien die in aller regel das trifft
auf alle zu nicht mehr auf ein einziges
element reduziert sind in ihrer
politischen darstellung sondern alle
inzwischen und die die es hier geht eine
politische breite darstellen und ich
glaube niemand bereit ist ein teil
komplett aufzugeben was dann auch dazu
geführt hat dass weil die
erwartungshaltung eine andere war die
fdp sich damals darüber beschwert hat
dass es in diesen ganzen
verhandlungsrunden über alle politischen
felder zu einer linksverschiebung
gekommen sei die durch die grünen
beeinflusst war
und man aber auf der anderen seite bei
punkten die ihnen besonders wichtig war
keine große rücksichtnahme
erkannt hat oder glaubt hat zu erkennen
und dann die sinnhaftigkeit zu einer
koalition abschließende frage gestellt
worden ist und deswegen gerade dazu wenn
wir zumindestens dabei sind in
sondierungen die uns angehen werden wir
diesen trugschluss nicht annehmen
sondern wissen dass wir über alle
politische felder verhandeln müssen mit
allen möglichen partnern und nicht nur
über steckenpferde
übrigen ging jetzt nicht mehr das
sozialminister was maximal macht und der
wirtschaftsminister
wirtschaftsministerin sozialministerin
das gegenteil macht oder wenn ein
umweltminister ministerin ja welcher
gott zum bleiben sagt jetzt wir
verschärfen die auflagen für landwirte
und landwirtschaftsminister oder
ministerin sagt das gegenteil
dann ist es zwar zu ihrer allgemeinen
belustigung und zur mehrarbeit aber zum
großen verdruss der bevölkerung als wenn
dann eine regierung für ein land